[Music]
quite whether we end up in a more or
less dangerous position if America
suddenly withdrew in its entirety
I might my suspicion will be
considerably more dangerous
I very much hope and believe that the
British people will convincingly decide
that their future lies in Europe it
doesn't lie as the 51st state of the
United States of America which is in any
case looking more and more in the other
direction
Europe would be I think the worse off if
America does retreat with the very very
good reasons it's got to retreat not
just the experience of Iraq and
Afghanistan
well thank you all very much for coming
to what I hope will be a really fun and
interesting session Jorge was saying
just and I ought to have been fears of
the Europeans not tears of the Europeans
we've exchanged Tears for Fears which is
a joke that will any work on any of you
over 30 probably but what this debate is
all about is how nervous and insecure or
indeed how happy Europe should be now
that the u.s. seems to more or less
withdrawn from public life to spend more
time with its family it's becoming a
much less unipolar world is there
something we should welcome or is it
something that should worry us that's
what we're going to be talking about the
format is that each of our three guests
is going to do a short three-minute
pitch what they think and we're then
going to open it up for discussion and
finally plenty of time for Q&A at the
end let me introduce them in turn Phil
Collins here on my right is a very good
political columnist on The Times he was
also chief leader writer there until
recently and before that he wrote
speeches for Georgia's great friend Tony
Blair he's also a visiting fellow at LSE
and associate editor at prospect which
Bronwyn Maddox edits she also used to be
at The Times actually as a foreign
editor and chief foreign commentator and
George Galloway needs little
introduction
until recently respect MP for Bradford
West he described his 2012 return to
office as the most sensational victory
in British history
how'd you describe May the seventh or
don't I ask right so we're gonna start
with Phil you make your pitch
well to the extent that America is
retreating from public life and to some
extent it is I don't regard that as
necessarily a good thing for Europe
there is no country and no power bloc
which has ever been the repository of
either good or evil in essence and there
are many things on which America has got
wrong and no doubt we'll go through some
of them I'd imagine we'd all agree on
them but they don't define the essence
of America and we may well look back a
hundred years hence those of us who are
still here and think that this was an
era in which American power was at least
as often benign as it was malign the
European project is of course a points
of real crisis a strange departure to a
single currency which even the time
looks a rather peculiar institutional
avenue to explore has brought the
European economies to their knees and
the very idea of Europe is now in
question was Europe was once a magnet
for countries and Europe was the answer
to a very real question which was how do
we rebuild the continent after a
terrible conflict that memory has faded
and Europe has struggled to find a
purpose it in a sense of victim of
success it did exactly what it was
designed for and then subsequently a
struggle to find a way to define itself
in a sought refuge in a series of
institutional changes such as a
constitution and a currency and it's led
it to the on past it's currently in of
course that goes hand in hand with the
economic decline and diplomatic and
cultural power always trials an economic
position - and we look across the world
and we see the rise of China and we see
the rise of India and we have there an
extraordinarily interesting experiment
in different models of development on
the one hand you have the raucous
vibrant democracy of India chaotic and
yet rather argumentative and and
marvelous economically not still not
wildly successful though growing more
rapidly than China for the first time a
long time and then you have the
authoritarian capitalist model of China
and you have the massive investment
across the world in in Africa and in
South America the
is China's contribution to its
diplomatic enterprise and that
competition between those two countries
strikes me as a fascinating laboratory
experiment in political systems
meanwhile we sit here cowering looking
at this massive monolith on one side the
United States and its India and China on
the other and we begin to wonder where's
I reckon I make future so I do think
it's we have a lot to be fearful about
and I think in that endeavor over time
the countries with whom we share a
language a culture and a tradition of
liberal democracy will be friends of
ours far off and them far more often
than they are enemies of ours
well I don't agree with the premise but
that's my job I don't accept that the
United States has anything like
withdrawn from public life it's heavily
engaged in Europe in Eastern Europe
Central Europe in the front line at the
Ukraine its bombing and coordinating
bombing in many other parts of the world
if that's the United States as an
isolationist power I'd hate to see them
if they got on to the front foot neither
do I accept Phil's apparent thesis at
the end there that we are somehow alien
to Europe because we don't speak the
same language as them and I don't think
that's widely shared amongst the British
people particularly they do say that you
know I meant it to enfold Europe and
Europe and America and together okay
the I thought when you mentioned the
common language which divides us
otherwise my apologies and I don't
accept the idea that Europe is somehow a
basket case London Paris Madrid Rome
Berlin pretty wonderful chain of
civilizations and places and peoples and
of course the other European capitals
too far from running away from Europe
most people in the world on the move at
the minute are trying to get into Europe
of course Europe has major problems but
the foremost amongst them is not the
fact that Uncle Sam might be less
prevalent in our affairs then he was
previously our fellow rightly had
embraced the challenges to the economy
and the currency and so on but I believe
that they will be overcome and we'll
have an early test of how the British
people feel about that of course it was
to be in 27
Dean might now be in 2060 might be as
early as May or June of 2016 and I very
much hope and believe that the British
people will convincingly decide that
their future lies in Europe it doesn't
lie as the 51st state of the United
States of America which is in any case
looking more and more in the other
direction neither does it lie in
glorious isolation so I see no need for
tears or fears the odd scrunching up of
the eyes the odd grimace maybe but
neither tears nor fears I believe in
Europe I believe that we are a European
people and I believe that the more
convincingly and sooner that we make
that decision that if you like defining
decision future defining decision the
better
well if I was forced to give a one-word
answer to this question I would say yes
better for us to be with America than
against it but it's the kind of question
that has so many things packed into it
yes the u.s. is a superpower but
actually in parts of the world that are
challenging what you might call Western
liberal values and China may be one of
those and parts of the Middle East at
another the u.s. can barely use those
attributes of being a superpower
certainly not to any kind of virus sure
success and I agree with Phil that it's
not really wanting to extend a wing to
let anyone shelter under it it is
pulling back really at its mood at the
moment is we want to go back home from
all these trouble spots there are
trouble spots and they're affecting
Europe as well as Europe's own problems
you might you know list some of those as
Russia China and parts of the Middle
East as parts of the world setting out
to challenge not just not just that have
individual fights but to challenge the
West and to challenge the idea of a rule
governed world over the kind that many
countries whether or not they've liked
America or like Europe have broadly
tried to sign up to since the Second
World War
now China to my mind is actually one of
the hardest of those the country under
its present leadership setting out very
assertively to say that the South China
Sea that marvelous melting pot of all
kinds of countries for thousands of
years well actually that's something of
a Chinese lake and but that is more of
America's problem to take on and the
countries around there it's not close to
us here in Europe the two that are
Russia into my view is not the biggest
problem but it depends a lot on how we
handle it now and there we could be
helped a lot by the United States and
the Middle East an awful painful tragic
mess as we can see every day at the
moment you and there are very very
different views about whether or not
America's action there is a plus or a
big minus my believe is it's it's been
both but one of the things that the
Obama administration is doing that I
think is really important
that Europe has really helped with is
the Iran deal not a perfect deal but if
it happens a really important step in
trying to bring some kind of stability
so there that's an example of where
Europe is working with America not under
its wing but pushing very hard to
achieve some kind of diplomatic result
and I think that's very much for the
better to just end with a kind of coda
of the American reluctance American kind
of fits of engagement with the world and
then pulling back there's been an ebb
and flow pretty much since the United
States was created and at the points of
its expansionist points people have
recoiled and said their get out of here
here is the great trampling power and
appoints when it's retreated people have
been tugging on its it's a sleeve or
wing if you like to use the metaphor of
the title and said won't you come back
well I don't think we're in supplicant a
position as that but Europe would be I
think the worse off if America does
retreat with the very very good reasons
it's got to retreat not just the
experience of Iraq and Afghanistan but
the huge increase of population that
it's got the complexity of politics that
that brings the passions and interests
in it to the east you know we have to
keep giving them a reason to be involved
in our in our interests in our concerns
and the reason is that I think the one
that Phil gave we share at heart common
interest common values yes many many
differences but common values which in
the end we want to defend and and and
see see established
so let's start with the I suppose the
core question which is is a world in
which the u.s. is less assertive a more
dangerous world or actually a better
world I'll start with you Phil well it's
very hard to answer that because we in a
way we've tried everything over the last
few years we tried the the processes of
intervention which was calamitous in its
consequence and and just now in Syria
we're seeing the process of inaction
which is also calamitous for a set of
different reasons in neither case can we
run through the counterfactual and see
what would have happened had we taken
the other course so it's very difficult
we tried in Libya somewhere some
intermediate point between the two with
a limited engagement which is also
calamitous in its consequences so it's
extraordinarily difficult there's a
great line that one somebody one of the
Americans once said about the
neoconservatives where they're nowhere
near conservative enough that they're
that of hubris of action but I'm also
conscious the fact that if we don't act
then then there are very dangerous
things too so quite whether we end up in
a more or less dangerous position if
America suddenly withdrew in its
entirety I might my suspicion will be
considerably more dangerous which is not
say America's perfect but for the
reasons Bronwyn gave that there are
attempts to restrain and withhold which
I think are valuable so if I had to give
a simple answer to that a very very
different question I think it will
become more dangerous if America
withdrew from the world well you know I
don't recognize this rules governed
world that Bronwyn talked about and Phil
just ran through some of the calamities
as he put them I have the advantage of
having predicted that there would be
calamitous in advance when our friends
were telling us they were the right
thing to do
did you predict that non intervention in
Syria would be calamitous yes I
predicted that the failure to support
Kofi Annan's political transition plan
when he was the UN special envoy to
Syria was going to prove calamitous so
yes I did
now the the idea that
the country's collection of countries
ourselves in the United States in
particular that illegally invaded and
occupied Iraq consent al-qaeda and Isis
cascading throughout the region and the
world are somehow a representative of a
rules governed world is ludicrous and it
shows the extent to which right wing
commentators see the the the moat in the
eye of the other but not the beam in
their own eye Russia and China are being
described here as on the verge of
lawless but it's we who are the lawless
powers not Russia or China Bronwyn I
think may have been Mary Ann said the
individuality but you all share I'm
indistinguishable from you as well you
all share a common worldview I'm the
only one here who's never worked at the
times or for prospect no but you work
for The Times yeah if you analyze the
point I made it's absolutely accurate
and the only person here who is neither
worked at at times nor prospect yes I
would if I wasn't being heckled nothing
has a China is monumental aggressiveness
and imagining that the South China Sea
was its orbit de pluie is in the name no
it is a the refrigerant names that I see
China see the world the one group of
people the one group of people who has
no rights of any kinds in the South
China Sea our Britain and the United
States if the Russian and Chinese navies
were at play out the North Sea just a
few miles from here I don't think we'd
be with
sanguine about you see my point that we
started the oppression channel
yes but the Chinese Navy is not in the
North Sea but the American Navy is in
the South China Sea it's this double
standard national waters it will the
north is also international waters but
you wouldn't be sanguine if the People's
Liberation Army forces were at play in
the North Sea because you have double
standards you imagine that the world is
a white man's burden and that we are
somehow given by God or someone else to
order the world and I reject that view
I'm sorry I just do I know that's an
unorthodox view on this platform but
it's mine alright Mary you said you've
wrote Russia is you don't recognize it
as a lawless thing well look it's taken
over Crimea and it's marched into
Ukraine do you know I don't know I don't
know Russian armed forces in Ukraine can
you show me a picture of them with all
your journalistic talent here can you
show me a single picture it is pushes
you know redefined it
it has backed yes it has backed as
Britain and the United States are
backing the rebels in Syria people back
others it's not the same as asserting
that the Russians are in the Ukraine
they're not George I don't I don't think
that parallel works at all and president
Putin's arguments that he's simply doing
it to hold at bay the colonialist
Emperor Enterprise of the European Union
EU and European Union he says which has
to me keep moving eastward and keep
sustaining itself by swallowing up more
countries yes he does say that and
indeed has said it to me you know this
is this is a fantasy that Russia is is
is putting out there you won't deny that
it has
taken over Crimea the Crimea was an
autonomous Republic it was not hugely of
Ukraine hugely populated by Russian PS
who were threatened by the right-wing
Ukrainian nationalists coup d'etat and
Kiev which burned the Parliament
overthrew the elected president and
appointed itself as power you see you
you just don't want to see these things
you want
look if Russia if Russia behaved in as
lawless away as the United States and
Britain have behaved over the last 20
years the world would be entirely in
flames but you don't see that you still
think of yourselves as part of a group
of law government people and you're just
not look Phil there's a good argument
for saying that the invasion of Iraq was
illegal and there's a good argument for
saying it wasn't illegal I mean I'm not
well well well well there is I mean I
mean in strictly speaking they did
well yes but he's not he's not the
jurisdiction either but but might I mean
I don't know I'm not a lawyer whether
it's legal or not the Attorney Journal
said ruled that it was a legal conflict
so insofar as I have a legal conflicts
insofar as we have a judgment II would
say it was a legal conflict there have
been plenty of conflicts before where we
think they have a strong moral
imperative that would have been deemed
to be illegal so whether or not that has
become the thing on which we we rest and
know we will never ever come to any kind
of settled view on that people are
ensconced in their views and in a sense
it's a pointless discussion to go back
through the question is that even if you
concede that it was of dubious legality
the notion that the United States and
Britain are serially lawless and on the
one hand and that Russia on is some sort
of great moral repository of legal
obligation is preposterous I mean
absolutely whatever you you went as a
general rule when you're on a platform
and an audience laughs at your point you
realize you've gone somewhere very
peculiar and you went somewhere very
peculiar well actually the audience
didn't laugh yes of the
audience laughter some of the audience
agree with me but this is not a tyranny
of who laughs and who doesn't
we're nano eyes another white
photography I mean we could all have
laughed at your assertion that the Iraq
war was legal you're the last man
standing saying that it was legal I
didn't say I'm standing seeing that it
was even if I were I wouldn't be as that
isn't that isn't the point
quite the United the United States
massacred millions of people in the
lifetime millions of people in the
lifetime of many of the people here in
Vietnam and caused the massacre of
millions more in Cambodia yet you parade
the United States some kind of lawful
benign force well that's not how it
looks from start how this sounds right
did the United States
well I'm quiet and I'll tell you both of
us were very clear in our remarks to say
at the beginning that we do not regard
the United States of America as some
sort of caricature example of perfect
goodness we both were very clear that no
country is in that position and that
though there are both there are on both
sides there are things which the United
States have done of which anyone would
be proud and things our wish you would
not now it is not good enough for you to
then pretend that our view of the United
States is some sort of cartoon in which
everything is rosy and gorgeous nobody
thinks that nobody thinks anything so
fundamentally and obviously stupid will
you be quiet there and give you all a
chance to speak actually there's
probably brahmins turn well I was just
gonna pick up on the South China Sea
thing that is a kind of colonial English
term they're about seven different names
all in the languages of the countries
around there for that see but none of
them attributed to to China the China
decades ago did something which is
called the nine dash line and drawn a
map
nine dashes enclosing most of that scene
which has been one of the you know most
most kind of richest cultural exchanges
of the world and certain kind of marked
it for itself along with the hundreds of
islands some of which it's now disputing
and others which it's not building
artificial new islands no other country
run those borders cleans the whole we
essentially the whole thing for itself
and it's wrong here to pick in English
on the one word China and say that this
this designates it but the most cone is
this debated over the years what are we
gonna call this fat shawarma yes it was
but Mayor you simply picking up on the
one word China and saying we must
because of that one word China in a
fifty-year-old term loosely wash the
United Nations oh we're going to give it
to China on that basis that the word
China appears in its name is is
ludicrous this is international
territory and which is a Chinese action
distressing all those countries around
there matter for China and the people
around about the sea to resolve it's
nothing to do with you it's nothing to
do George to be first promise you did
say earlier on it's not something that
should concern Britain or Europe from
anything else from a defense pact a
closed defense pact with Japan that goes
back to the end of the Second World War
which is fundamental to Japan Japan's
the stance of not building up a military
to the defense pacts so defense pacts
have nothing to do with right or wrong
legal not legal moral not moral their
defense pacts at the end of the war you
can't rebuild your military that was
both a moral and a practical thing and
given how threatening Japan had been
during the war and that in return the
quid pro quo was that they could shelter
under the US Japan had much choice in
that arrangement but what happened was
the United States based a huge United
States military force there including
nuclear weapons
they did not do so to stop any large
backwards to revanche ISM amongst the
Japanese people they did so for their
own self-interest as the world dominant
power now what my two friends are really
crying about if we're talking about
tears is that they're no longer top dog
China is already a bigger economy than
the United States the day is coming and
very soon when no one in the world will
tell China what to do that's what
they're really crying about because they
preferred it when Uncle Sam and John
Bull could alter the world we haven't
said that at all this point of Mary
Alice coming on to I think that's my
interpretation of why you're really my
view of multipolar world is much better
it reflects the development of many many
countries many countries finding their
voice finding the way to express
themselves on the world stage finding
the way to assert their rights it's much
better for the world of the many many
millions of the people in it and I don't
think the world's where America could
have its own way ever really existed but
it is a bit of a caricature but I think
the world of the world is better this
way I said right at the beginning
even though America is you know still a
superpower pretty well by anyone's
definition in the parts of the world
where it is being challenged that China
and the Middle East
actually that power and America knows
this perfectly well that power may not
account for very much it can't take on
China it does not want a war with China
it has held back from intervention in
the Middle East and is really very very
tentative about what to do there so
America is not behaving like a
superpower oh that is trampling all over
the world or is it expects to have any
success from doing so so I think that's
a character to a past and and and
present
okay can we can we just Park the u.s.
for a minute now and look at the current
state of the world and whether Europe
does face dangerous threats should we be
worried about China should we be perhaps
more worried about Putin's Russia is the
Middle East a threat Britain and Europe
or just only in its own region can we
talk about that and figure just forget
in America for now
well yes Europe faces problems I don't
think it faces I don't fear China I mean
I very much agree with what Brahman just
said about the multipolar world in which
America is one voice amongst many I
don't think anybody either thinks it's
feasible that America would be the
dominant power or things it's especially
desirable but Europe's Europe faces a
whole series of problems within its own
borders as well as those from outside it
faces the serious question of how it
earns its living in the world and I
don't think we have any real answer to
that question we are Europe is
struggling to find a an economic purpose
and economic future for itself and a lot
of its other problems derive from that
now the idea that Europe is going to be
a major part of any foreign adventures
in a in a period of a deep economic
decline I think it's very unlikely
indeed so it's principal problems derive
internally of trying to work out how on
earth we make this economic union work
for the people who are living in it that
the the principal problem facing the 350
or 400 millions of us in the European
continent is how to order our own
affairs how to get our own economies
back on to their feet to find us fill
put a role for ourselves what we
actually going to do to earn our living
in his words these are very big and very
worthy topics for our attention and it's
my point that we should be fretting less
about others and making sure that our
own house is in order now
I alluded to earlier I think and I've
traveled the world not as much as
Bronwyn maybe as much as Phil I think
Europe is the best place to live in the
world today
for all its problems in terms of its
social peace lack of crime relatively
the civilization the ancient and
collected civilizations that I
represents it's actually a beacon a
haven it's a wonderful place to be by
comparison with most other places in the
world that's quite a good start
and the sooner Britain plays a full and
engaged role in that the better it will
be for us and for Europe the Middle East
is a total catastrophe everything that
could have been done wrong has been done
wrong from the sykes-picot fake
artificial division of the Arab
countries double-dealing as usual at the
end of the first world war ii the
buttressing of tyranny throughout the
intervening period through in one case
supporting Islamist fanaticism in one
country but opposing it in another
country and supporting it again in a
third country opposing it in a fourth
our policy is a total catastrophe and
Libya is a very good case in point
Gaddafi was probably the worst the most
crazed of all the Arab leaders phil's
ex-boss thought he could do business
with him and did quite successful didn't
you purchase tyranny by supporting
Saddam Hussein I'll come to Saddam
Hussein if you would like if they have
if they hadn't overthrown Saddam Hussein
there would be no Isis and there would
be no al-qaeda cascading around the
world before the Iraq saga fact there
would be no Isis in Iraq there would be
no Isis in Syria now Isis control
one-third of each country but don't let
him off the hook with Libya his former
body yes your former boss was the best
of friends with Gaddafi I've never met
Gaddafi or any member of his grisly
family
unlike Mr Blair I'm not blaming Phil
Fatah he was only the hired hand but my
point is I wasn't gonna happen Gaddafi
was a disaster Gaddafi was a disaster it
takes real genius
to make Libya 10 50 100 times worse
after Gaddafi then it was under Gaddafi
you use your oblique you're implying
that we've got this all the decisions
actually made it was look there's many
there are no good decisions in some of
these but hey keep making the worst
decisions you can't so you come along
what do you know the United States the
movies re forgive me for mentioning it
again does it back Saudi Arabia what is
it not either way
absolutely horrible decision vacuum
sound eerie but very problematic regime
confounding all its values on the other
hand of Saudi Arabia blows up even worse
you can call it in retrospect you can be
able to call whatever it does probably
the worst decision it is not a region
where there are good decisions at the
moment there
the question is just what can we do to
improve it and it seems this is Europe's
problem we can't attach
I completely agree what you've both with
what you've both said about your
problems at the moment being about how
to organize itself
and how to give itself a sense of
identity and how to have do things make
things that actually are going to raise
productivity and wages in the years to
come and it's in Europe still struggling
to recover from the current
globalization that has has hit it and it
hasn't got an answer that even the next
week we don't know if it's got an answer
to the eurozone problems but all that
the Russia question as I said I think is
is is a threat but not the biggest one I
think the Middle East however much a
mess
whatever the record of bad decisions we
are where we are Europe through many
countries Italy France Britain
intimately connected to those countries
and we can't cut ourselves off from them
even if we wanted to and I think we
really do have to try and make decisions
about what we can do at these points
Libya could possibly still be open to
some kind of diplomacy fanciful as it
sounds because it's the only possible
way you could see of trying however
black it seems trying to bring some kind
of peace to that is to get the three or
four bits of the country that it's now
broken into to talk to each other
it may be fanciful
the alternative is worse Yemen possibly
we can we can help the alternative is to
sit back and I let the more fight and I
don't think that's something that we
want to do George do you think that
Putin has felt emboldened by America's
not quite withdraw from public life but
you know but Obama clearly didn't want
to get involved in any more military
conflicts I mean I get the sense that
Putin thought our great now no one's
going to oppose me wholly engaged in
Ukraine on Russia's front line the
Victoria Nuland former ambassador now at
the State Department told us of the
billions of dollars that she spent
subverting the power in the Ukraine John
McCain and all the other neocon Hawks
well whenever off the streets and the
coup that took place in the Maidan what
is it now 18 months ago is is the the
cause of the confrontation between US
and Russia I don't see that Putin has
done anything wrong
anywhere else he frustrated Western
policy in Syria that's true but that
wasn't wrong I don't see where of this
chargesheet against Putin is drawn up
from now Russia is a capitalist country
with an elect Russia's a normal
capitalist country with run by a
kleptocracy it it is run by a
kleptocracy but not quite as
kleptocratic as the Yeltsin era which
was of course healed by right-wing
people in Britain as some kind of golden
era the reason Putin is popular in
Russia is because he's taking some of
the wealth back from the kleptocrats
now till himself I don't think it's to
himself I don't see where you're you
know respected journalists I don't know
why you would make such an assertion on
tape without the remotest piece of
evidence to support it you saying he's
not corrupt I'm not
I'm saying that he's not taking money
for himself where's the evidence
give me your evidence that Putin is
stealing money for himself I didn't say
that I absolutely no no you're talking
about it I'm in control
yes but I'm talking about the power and
control of a lot of the key companies
and around
Bronwen you've said for himself I'm
sorry yes I did but I didn't say he's
stealing money for himself we're now
getting into splinters of sentences
perhaps that he is rewriting mr. king is
giving Russia back some of its perceived
national dignity that it lost under
Yeltsin well you can laugh if you like
but that's how Russians see it now my
point is that's why the protests on the
streets in every streets Bronwen there
are protests in London but that doesn't
mean that the majority of Russians don't
support Putin my point is I don't know
why you needed to have a confrontation
with Putin he's not my man is your man
I'm a leftist he's not if I could choose
the government of Russia
it wouldn't be Putin he's a man that
thinks like you he believes in
capitalism free markets national states
I don't know why you needed to fall out
with them that's my point
China is a different kettle of fish it
has a different ideal ideology but
Russia doesn't sometimes interventions
are so self satirizing that there's no
need to say anything I thought you said
ad hominem was off the adopted
manama tax today but there we go alright
so how should you not meant that Phil
had nothing to see by the way
let's just talk about how a weather
Europe should respond to any of these
threats now you know Britain used to
spend 2% of its GDP on defense it no
longer does even under a Conservative
government we're all drawing in our
horns because of the financial situation
mainly is this a good idea can we just
afford to say we don't need to defend
ourselves at any to the degree that we
used to is that safe brahmam I don't
think it's just a matter of defense
about how we respond I think we as
Europe most need to respond we're
talking about Putin to the three Baltic
states and to their concerns yes they've
got big Russian populations some of whom
might prefer to join Russia some of whom
might like to have a Russian passport as
they're being offered as well as well as
their national passports these are these
are three countries that were part of
the Soviet Union not just the Soviet
bloc and their membership of the EU and
NATO so they have now has been
particularly provocative to to Putin as
he expresses it their concern now that
if Russia moved or strengthened its
control on around their borders that
they would feel more cut off from from
Europe
well reasserting that they are part of
you and a NATO and repeatedly doing so I
think is is useful but our response
isn't just about defense I agree with
phil earlier that it also has to be
about sorting out europe's own ability
to run itself because that's part of its
claim to be a part of the world that
many people as well as George want to
live in that the fact that we're very
attractive to people which I agree this
is I agree Europe is the best place in
the in the world to live I think that's
true and that has a magnetic attraction
to many many people and one of the ways
in which the world laps up on our shores
is literally you know boats in the
Mediterranean and the movements of
people the movements of people from
places of conflict and disaster towards
Europe we cannot hope to think that
Europe can somehow be isolated from the
world in in that sense people are moving
capital is always moving the world
economy is deeply integrated now so then
Oshin that we can somehow withdraw and
and think that we can live our own
little life behind fortress Europe again
not true it's not true politically it's
not true diplomatically it's not true in
the sense that there are those people
who want to do as harm from time to time
the world is so deeply enmeshed that the
idea that we can be isolationist I think
is is a fallacy something we've lost and
I never quite understand George where
you end up with your view you take all
of your view doesn't not lead to a kind
of isolationist position as sort of
quiet ISM and I don't say that as a in
order to be critical and inquiry that it
isn't that the implication that the the
the the best response if actually we
take all of your views is no response at
all is to let the world be as it is
where it is and for us to remain within
our boundaries quietly that getting on
with our life now I'm not I'm asking you
whether that's the opposition not
attributing it to you but but if it is
that just that doesn't seem realistic in
the world we live in
well of course this session is not about
me or about my views if you would like
me to I will of course say actually
nothing could be further from the truth
I'm not a pacifist very far from it I
believe we have to defend ourselves I
think that the choice of a new
generation of nuclear weapons and the
submarines to platform them is very bad
choice in defense terms I believe that
we should defend our borders we should
defend our European borders we should
defend our British borders we should
organize ourselves so that our state and
our state's collection of states are a
far more successful Enterprise than they
than they currently are we have
interests elsewhere if anyone threatens
our interests we have a right to defend
them but that's not what we've been
doing when you go halfway around the
world to invade another country and
overthrow its government on a tower of
lies you're not defending your interest
you're imperiling your
interests as everyone from the former
head of mi5 to most sentient beings in
the land have already concluded that we
actually damaged our own interests by
invading and occupying Iraq and it's not
finished yet not by a long chalk so you
asked me what I would do I wouldn't do
what you have already done what you and
the people that you supported have
already done and I said so at the time
the last conversation I ever had with
mr. Blair
was this the fall of Baghdad two weeks
before the war the fall of Baghdad will
not be the beginning of the end
merely the end of the beginning number
two there are no al-qaeda in Iraq but if
you and Bush invade and occupy it there
will be hundreds of thousands of our
Qaida and not just in Iraq but in our
own countries and I was right I mean at
least have the grace to acknowledge that
I was right and he was wrong you were
right mother so I'd like to thank Phil
Collins very much George Galloway
Bronwyn Maddox and all of you feel great
[Applause]
[Music]